(bright music)
- [Narrator] Some of the
oldest windmills in the world
can be found on the gusty border
of northern Iran and Afghanistan.
(bright electronic music)
Nashtifan is a city located
in the Khorasan Province of Iran.
The city name was previously Nishtufan,
translating to "storm sting,"
which is appropriate for this windy city.
A 65-foot wall blocks the
intense gale-force winds,
and on top of that wall
are around two dozen
vertical axis windmills.
They are made from clay, straw, and wood,
and it's estimated that
they were constructed
over 1,000 years ago.
The windmills still function today
and can be used to mill grain into flour.
In 2002, Nastifan was recognized
as a National Heritage Site
by Iran's Cultural Heritage Department,
in the hopes that it will be around
for thousands of years to come.